hi i'm priyanka and today i'll be
talking to you about
serverless api development after a quick
introduction i'll also
provide a demo of how to build and
manage serverless apis with the google
cloud api gateway so stick around
[Music]
adoption of serverless computing offers
a profound paradigm shift in developers
ability to create
highly scalable applications and
services
this architecture considerably improves
the way modern applications and services
are created
by allowing developers to build without
worrying about the setup and maintenance
of the underlying infrastructure and by
adding an api
facade to these serverless applications
developers can
seamlessly connect data integrate
systems and build modern applications
as organizations are expanding their api
programs
a key question continues to come up how
do we make apis lightweight
on the client side yet highly scalable
and secure
to meet the changing traffic demands to
accomplish this
many organizations have been migrating
their business critical apis to
serverless architecture
developers package serverless functions
as restful apis
to increase security of their services
with monitoring and controlling access
to data
protecting these services from bot
attacks and other malicious traffic
improving performance with rate limiting
and caching
and identifying important insights from
analytics
data extracted from monitoring alerting
logging and tracing
with google cloud api gateway you can
create
secure and monitor apis for google cloud
serverless backends
it enables you to provide secure access
to your backend services
through a well-defined rest api that is
consistent across
all your services regardless of the
service implementation
it can manage apis for multiple backends
including cloud functions cloud run app
engine
compute engine and google kubernetes
engine
build on onward api gateway is fully
managed by google cloud
to give you high performance scalability
and the freedom to focus
on development api gateway gives you
all the operational benefits of
serverless apis
while reducing the complexity of
implementation such as
flexible deployment and scalability so
that you can focus on building
great applications additionally google
cloud api gateway adds
layers of security control such as
authentication and key validation
by configuring security definitions that
require
all incoming calls to provide a valid
api key
it also allows you to set quotas and
specific usage limits to protect your
apis
from abuse or excessive usage let's take
a quick look
here at google we continue to see a lot
of developers building their apis
on top of microservices so in this
example
we've deployed a weather api on cloud
run
it's made up of four different services
this is great for you
as an api provider because it gives you
a lot of flexibility around how you
deploy and scale these services
but as an api consumer you don't want to
keep track
of which service is responsible for
which piece of the api
you just want one interface that you can
call to access
all the capabilities provided by this
api
so let's take a look at how google
cloud's api gateway
can help you combine all these services
into one easy to use api
to get started we will need an open api
specification that defines each of the
resources
in our api next we will add instructions
that tell the api gateway where to route
the request
for each of those resources and finally
we will want to secure our apis so
we will configure a security definition
that requires
all the incoming calls to provide a
valid api
once we have our open api specification
and we are ready to create our api
gateway
first we'll specify the display name and
give our api
a unique identifier next we will define
the api's
initial configuration by uploading our
open api
file we'll then give our configuration a
display name
and configure the service accounts that
will be used to call our backend
services
and finally we are ready to deploy our
api configuration to a new
gateway in this case that gateway will
run
in the us central region once we hit
create
after a few minutes our gateway will be
ready to start accepting
incoming api request because we've
secured our api
we will need valid credentials in this
case we've elected to use api keys
as our security mechanism so we can get
an api key for our api and the apis in
service section
of the google cloud console once we have
our key we can make an api call from the
command line using chrome
if we try to access our api without
providing a key
the call will be rejected by the gateway
once we add our key to the request the
gateway then allows our call to go
through successfully
that was just a quick preview of how you
can use
google cloud api gateway to create and
secure your apis
you can leverage api gateway for a
number of important use cases such as
abstracting back in complexity to
facilitate development for web and
mobile applications
connecting users to in-house and
third-party apis and services
especially those provided by google
cloud
controlling access for partners while
rate limiting the number of calls for
each partner
and extending data services to enable
frictionless service oriented access to
data
now it's your turn to try it out get
started by clicking the link in the
description below